oh cool cryptex can I have it no no you
can't where'd you get it how do you know
what a cryptex is I know what things are
well Leslie hid the location of our
Valentine's meeting place in here know
every five letter word that has anything
to do with our third date we tried it's
a four-letter word add an S I really
don't think it's that I wish I could
help you bro I don't know if I can
you're like the second smartest guy I
know you should go to the first smartest
guy I know
okay so the clue is inside but it takes
a five-letter code to open an D did you
try ah
yes yeah I said everyone's first
suggestion just smart people I think I
might be able to help you told you let
me see it I'll show you I can unroll it
the murals with this heart you see look
to the first and there your next clue
will be the first letter of the name of
each murals hard on it will spell out
the clue or something or something let's
check out the murals
[Music]
this scented candle ándale ándale which
i found in the men's bathroom room room
represents the eternal burning of
competition serves something that smells
like cookies miss it does yes it does my
friend okay we will be competing for
gold silver and bronze yogurt lids now
the bronze are really blue and they're
also the backside of the gold so no
flipping okay on our system I do play
games I think and I dangle things in
front of my cats I play lots of games
just not at work let the games begin
[Music]
[Applause]
alright then once when the other hallway
are cornfield slaughter lament of the
buffalo needless slaughter slaughter
gone wrong
eating the Reverend it's raining blood
and death everywhere great I got it from
here thanks guys I hope I didn't screw
up your Valentine's Day too much okay no
April hates Valentine's Day and brunch
and outside and smiling she's weird I
figured it out the letters unscrambled
say no food finer clue three at JJ's
diner how many clues are there exactly
you have what is the national sport of
Icelandic paper companies and I'm
blanking on the name could you help me
out Pam Jim they refer to it as long
curtain hmm in English box of paper
snowshoe racing fair enough but I like
flonkerton the thing about Jim is when
he's excited about something like the
office Olympics he gets really into it
and he does a really great job but the
problem with Jim is that he works here
so that hardly ever happens so who will
be challenging Kevin in flonkerton
anyone
do it yes Phyllis put your foot right
through here right through the flow gold
medal in Flemington thank you delegate
from Iceland Wow okay no one else should
even try gold medals Wow there is no
food finer for Leslie that means whipped
cream or no it's whipped cream we're
looking the whipped cream cans Oh got
some okay Something Wicked This Way
Comes
once you peruse a book with your thumbs
go to the one who succumbs I'll be
attached with a little gum unless they
give me a break I hate riddles and other
such nonsense I want that on the record
but something wicked with a book is my
ex-wife from the library which means I'm
the one that succumbs I'll be attached
with a little gum good God that woman is
good follow me to the sheltered snow
only 22 clues left to go 22 well this is
the woman I've chosen to love Ted really
ten that's your guess you're a
professional accountant there's no 10
Greenland's 42 I'm gonna say 50 50 100
come on that is like the strategy it's
called being smart thank you
I don't know how the whole betting thing
started but it's fun chubbs out damn it
forty-eight forty-nine
Oh he's not there he has spent hours up
here every sex
with you hours and hours okay okay no
constantly like four years okay hello my
name is Ron Swanson
I believe Leslie Knope may have left
some kind of scavenger hunt clue here
she did one second
[Music]
gentlemen
[Music]
enjoy your evening so number five
becomes number four number six becomes
number five number three becomes number
two etc etc and let's just say that I
just sent back Love Actually which was
awesome and they sent me uptown girls
which is also awesome but guess what now
I want to see Love Actually again but
it's at the bottom of the queue oh no
what do I do what I do is this I go
online I go click click click and I
change the order of the queue so I can
see Love Actually as soon as I want to
it's so easy Ryan do you really not know
how Netflix works I guess I forgot Ryan
well done 2 minutes 42 seconds
additionally Pam you went 10 because she
said awesome 12 times and Jim you went
five because she mentioned six or a man
in comedies well they always say break
glass in case of an emergency
wait a second well there we go hey so I
got 9 3 & 4 I have 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 and 19 oh I got I got lucky and I
love riddles go pound some clues also
found this weird stick might be a clue
no okay did you find the 25th clue no I
got number 8 number 22 we failed
I just had a little more time she's
waiting for me somewhere in Pawnee and
I'm not gonna be there
wait Leslie loves romance but she also
loves being a right is there something
you used to disagree on but you've since
come around to her way of thinking Ron
you're a genius
my heart is very full at this moment and
for dwight schrute the silver metal like
silver metal yeah always get his gold ye
plain nationally cuz your condos in
America
[Music]
about to have a sack those are the doves
[Music]
Leslie thanks to your annoying prying
last year I'm sure you remember my
birthday is coming up I know I know no
parties you hate parties correct oh you
know that wild goose chase you sent Ben
on for Valentine's Day scavenger hunt I
also do not want that yep I understand I
absolutely do not want to solve a series
of riddles and clues each more intricate
than the last you understand what I'm
saying yeah I got it run good oh I do
want that please do this for me
you